[Music]
it is
oxymoronic to think that generosity
adds to prosperity
you would think if i had a bigger pile
of money because i hadn't given some
away that i would be more prosperous
and the truth is the opposite happens
and it happens so often
that it is a principle now for those of
us that are people of faith
evangelical christians were taught and
believe that the bible says
that we're to give a tenth of our income
to our local church
a tenth a tithe which is a hebrew word
obviously an old english word
representing a hebrew word
but it literally the word means tenth
one tenth of our income
now you may or may not agree with that
that's not up for discussion you can
agree with it and if you do that's fine
if you don't then i get to do it it's my
faith i get to choose you get to choose
what you do
i'm not telling you you have to do
something but that's what
my faith teaches as an evangelical
christian
and um here's the interesting thing
about that
the bible says in malachi a testimony in
this says the lord of hosts
god says test me talking about the tithe
he's discussing the tithe right before
that regarding the tithe
test me god says test me
and see if i will not throw open the
windows of heaven
and pour out for you a blessing
that you cannot contain
and i will rebuke the devourer
for your sakes now the word blessing
there does not mean bmw in the hebrew
it is not necessarily the word blessing
is not
necessarily money or wealth
now sometimes people on the prosperity
side of the christian world
quote that scripture and says god
promises to bless you financially
if you tithe that's not what the word
says
the word is the word barakah b-e-r-k-a-h
and if you look it up in the strong's
concordance which is where you get an
english translation
of the hebrew word you'll find that word
b-e-r-k-a-h
means peace refreshment
as a camel finds
in an oasis at an oasis there's always
shade
there's always water
as opposed to a dry parched desert
now reread that test mean this says the
lord of hosts and see if i will not
throw open for you
the windows of heaven and pour out for
you a blessing
that you cannot contain peace
as a camel finds at an oasis
that you cannot contain now what ends up
happening
whether you're a person of faith or not
here's the principle that works
and it works again you don't there's no
it's not unique
to christianity although it manifests
itself well within the
christian theology what happens is this
it's almost impossible to be a miserable
person when you are a generous person
generous people are almost always
happier
a lower incidence of depression among
generous people
very few people that are generous are
depressed
it's very unusual almost never happens
generous people are attractive
they smile more they're not attractive
because people want to be around them to
get money from them that's not the point
the point is that generosity is not just
an act it is a character quality that
induces several acts like integrity
integrity is not an act you have
integrity you are a person
of integrity you are a generous
person it is a character quality like
honesty integrity
kindness it's something now if you're a
kind person that's the quality
when you when you out of your kindness
you do something if you're a
compassionate person
that's the quality out of that you're
compassionate to someone
then that's the verb that comes out of
your character quality
and i think we can all agree joyful
people
generous people compassionate people
kind people
are all more attractive oh couldn't we
use a little more of that
attractiveness in our culture today
there's a lot of just ugliness
out there today and most of it is born
in fear
which is not attractive most of it is
born in
anger which is not attractive most of it
is born in selfishness
versus selflessness which is not
attractive
so here's what ends up actually
happening the people who
have as a steady part of their financial
diet
the rhythm of their life they are
generous
people who tithe their weekly paycheck
to their local church
people who give regularly not just
once a year not randomly but as a part
of the rhythm of your life like
breathing and bathing you're giving
you're catching somebody at the gas pump
and you just buy their gas
you buy the person behind you at the
starbucks lines next order
i don't care what it is those are little
tiny things maybe you do some nice big
things maybe you
pay for an orphanage to be built maybe
you pay for a hospital to be built i
don't care how many zeros there are on
it
but when people have a regular rhythm of
generosity they are a different kind of
a person
and they're very attractive and people
want to be around them and they want to
have them
as employees and they want to work
for people like that as an employer
they are easier to work business deals
with
they're not functioning in fear and
anger all the time
there's a little different sense of
confidence and competence
and you know what all that leads to
more money
generous people have a tendency to
prosper because of that
it's not really because they gave the
money away it's because their heart and
who they were
as a person was changed when they gave
the money away
and it made them attractive and
attractive people have more of a
tendency to prosper than unattractive
people
i mean think about it if you're an
employer and you're sitting there and
you're looking at two candidates
that are up for promotion one of them is
going to get the job one isn't
one of them is miserable angry fearful
all the time every time you look at them
they look like they were weaned on a
pickle
and you look at the other one and
they're smiling and they hold the door
open and they always put others first
and they're thinking about how they can
make everything better instead of how
they can make themselves better
and bigger they're equal in their
talents
but that one character quality
distinguishes the two of them apart who
gets the promotion everybody answer with
me the generous person
that's who gets the promotion generous
people have a tendency to prosper
who you're going to hire to do your lawn
care
who you're going to hire to fix your car
how are you going to hire to do your
hair who are you going to hire to
someone's weaning on a pickle someone's
angry all the time and selfish and
they're figuring how they can cut every
corner on you
or someone's got a little margin in
their life there's a little wiggle room
in their spirit everything's not so
freaking tight
they're not about to explode all the
time
now tell me generous people don't
prosper i've watched it for decades
and this is why you will hear regularly
a testimony and it's not a
mystical weird christian thing but
you'll hear a couple like that last
couple doing their debt-free scream that
says
you know we started giving away 10 of
our income because we thought we should
we were convicted of that by god's
spirit we thought god was telling us to
do that that's exactly what you heard
them say
and yet they got out of debt three
months faster than their original plan
in almost half the time of their
original plan
did the math really change no their
income went up only a little bit they
were able to sell his car
but what changed was them
be not conformed to this world
don't be normal normal sucks
you don't want to be normal don't be
like this world
be transformed how you transformed
the renewing of your mind you change
your mind you get information you didn't
have and you install it into your hard
drive
and the operating system is permanently
changed
it's called living like no one else so
that later you can live
and give like
no one else